this is a program I've been wanting to
do on alternative views for 17 years
and that is have an interview with
former CIA officer Phil Agee now we have
had some programs with Phil you have
seen some speeches that he has given
that we had copies of and presented them
to you and on the documentary on company
business but this is our first chance to
actually talk with him in person
Phil was in the CIA for 12 years and
then quit after he saw what the CIA was
actually doing all the terrible things
doing in the areas where he was working
particularly in Ecuador Mexico and
ludecke why he resigned in 1969 to write
his first big book inside the company or
CIA diary since then he's written five
books the last one being on the run
which tells about his experiences after
he got out of the CIA when he was in
Europe and trying to write his book and
the CIA was hounding him from country to
country doing everything it could to
keep him from writing this book well
Phil we're so pleased that you can
finally be with us I'm very happy to be
here very happy to be here you've had
such an association with the CIA both
positive and negative for so many years
let's start out by talking about where
the CIA is today they say they want to
do intelligence gathering on economic
subjects rather than political etc like
they had in the past what do you think
about that well I think that that's a
normal activity they've been doing that
since the beginning to speak of it as
something new is really inaccurate in
this context of all this talk about
economic and financial and commercial
intelligence collection as a new role
for the agency I got out a document
which was sent to me anonymously in 1976
20 years ago practically and this
document was it was the list of the what
they call key intelligence questions for
1975 in this very field economic
commercial financial intelligence also
high-tech developments and all in the
developed countries all in allies like
the NATO allies and Japan and this is a
was an innovation of William Colby when
he came into the CIA in 1973 he tried to
systematize and organize organize the
foreign intelligence collection process
and for 1975 there were I think 69 key
intelligence questions and these are
actually questions with some detail and
then there's a whole discussion of them
that follows from 1 to 69 but these were
only on this document there were only
the the 9 which deal with economic and
commercial and financial matters and I
got that out in and it calls for great
great detail on all of these matters
including the negotiating positions the
fallback positions on such negotiations
as the general agreement on tariffs and
trade now the WTO and all of it was in
its most important parts spying on
allies and the State Department was
supposed to get this type of information
the CIA would get it get it in its way
secretly or through some kind of
technical means or through agents and so
I just point that document out that's 20
years ago and they were doing it for 20
years before that I would assume then
they would turn this information over to
the corporation's the multinational
corporations that I can't be sure of
they would send it in of course to the
analysts and they would then be
preparing reports for use within the
government in the commerce department
you know and within the White House and
the National Security Council and its
staff but the decision to turn it over
to commercial companies or
multinationals is something which I
can't really say that they did that then
but we did help the multinationals in
different ways from time to time to time
my very first job in the CIA after the
training program was to I was assigned
to the latin-american division to the
Venezuela desk and my job it was it was
so boring I had to do name checks
and a name check is where you get a name
from in this case Caracas our office in
Caracas in the embassy and you you make
a request for all the records on this
particular person from the records
integration division or our ID that's
where the files were and then you were
looking for anything negative
politically negative in other words or
derogatory it happened that these lists
of names that I was getting every week
were given to us in Caracas by the chief
of security of Creole petroleum
and Creole petroleum you know was the
largest overseas subsidiary of xso or
now Exxon a standard or a of New Jersey
in other words and so we were performing
this security check in order to help
them keep political undesirables out of
employment because these were people who
are prospective employees for Creole and
so we were doing these checks on
Venezuelans actually and serving the
interests of of of this enormous
Standard Oil Exxon xso subsidiary abroad
this is one example and I can tell you
when I got out of that job I was very
happy because it's just boring you can
imagine to try to go through all these
different records and look for something
that might be derogatory and then have
to write it back and and the first name
I got was Jose Diaz and didn't even have
a date of birth so you can imagine how
many how many files I had on Ho's ideas
such as it is the most kind of like John
Mayer or say well this is when they say
they're going to start doing economic
intelligence now and that helping out
the quote us unquote corporations
they've really been doing that all along
it's just a kind of taking the mask off
of it because everywhere they have the
CIA has actually been making the that
particular country safe and profitable
for the multi oh yes corporations and
local elite yes everything goes back to
that in a matter of fact this
intervention abroad for stability for
the optimum operating conditions for
us-based multinationals is something
that predates even certainly world war
two and in some respects you could say
it even predates the Bolshevik
Revolution because it's a more than 100
years now that that the leadership in
this country has understood that there
is no way to preserve the system in this
country without foreign markets for
surplus production without foreign labor
cheap labor and without the cheapest
possible national national natural
resources and this is something which
had been going on for 100 years and all
through the Cold War and so it is
something that's going to continue for
the future but in this economic and
commercial area there have been two
cases this year of operations that went
bad one was in France in February when
the French government caught the CIA
trying to recruit people in the French
government for secret information on
French negotiating positions within the
World Trade Organization context and
they they ordered five CIA people out of
the country
that was the news at that time in
February four of them including its
chief of station were in the embassy
undercover as diplomats you know and
then there was a fifth one a woman who
was outside the embassy she was under
some non-official cover I don't know
what that was but that was the news at
that time and then it came comes out
much later just a few weeks ago that as
a result of this and of the of the
reaction of the French government the
strong reaction to this attempt to
penetrate their government the whole CIA
operation in Paris in France was shut
down including whatever they were doing
against international terrorism the
narcotics trade and so forth that's one
case that went bad on them this year
another one that went bad just a few
weeks ago was the leakage to the press
which wasn't eventually confirmed it's
true the CIA was spying on the Japanese
negotiators last summer in the trade of
the auto talks you know how we're trying
to get into their market and so forth
and the CIA was monitoring the
communications I believe of the Japanese
negotiators and the appropriate ministry
and also the companies themselves so
that our side that some the mickey
kantor
side would have a better knowledge of
what they would accept on what they
wouldn't accept and so this has soured
relations with japan also so when you
get into this area of spying on your
allies you you're asking for a lot of
trouble and whether they give that to
the companies or not it's difficult to
say i can't tell you of course they've
been doing this type we talk about the
japanese they've been doing that type of
monitoring of communications and for for
years for decades this is nothing new i
guess it just now came out yes and as i
mentioned it went goes back at least
twenty years and in 20 years before that
but one area that ought not to be
forgotten is cuba because there is a 35
year economic blockade going against
cuba still and there are those people
who are trying to intensify this and
broaden it still more now the CIA
without the slightest doubt has the
requirement in every country to report
on any possible trade deals that cuba
may be interested in making or
investment in cuba now that the country
has opened up and the CIA has got to
collect this information so that
measures can be taken to to sabotage
these possible deals of interest and
benefit to cuba i was there last year
and i was in a meeting being addressed
by roberto robin inna he is the foreign
minister very young hip guy and he was
telling us that of every ten possible
deals they have for investment in cuba
or for trade and the united states is
able to squash nine and so they know
perfectly well that every move they make
as they go around the world in in trade
negotiations or in seeking investment
for whatever in cuba they are being
followed and watched under a microscope
so that some measure can be taken it
could be the ambassador with the local
government it could be any
way they can approach the person and put
the pressure on there's a good example
of this further
the Soviets built in a large petroleum
refinery very near cienfuegos which is
the main city on the south coast this
was never put into operation before the
collapse of the Soviet Union and then
there were there was a diminution in
trade and the Cubans finally convinced
or made a deal with the Ecuadorians who
which are one of the principal exporting
countries and they were to bring the
petroleum from Ecuador to Cuba to this
refinery refine the products and
re-export leaving behind a certain
amount of production to pay for the use
of the refinery this was going to be a
great deal for Cuba because they have an
energy crisis it is terrible the United
States was able to put the fist down on
Ecuador and it fell through so the
Cubans made a deal with the Venezuelans
because eventually you know they they
nationalize Creole and solid national
industry now the Venezuelans then we're
going to bring the petroleum to this
refinery and re-export leaving surplus
production behind for the Cubans the
same thing happened bang the cue the
Venezuelans had to withdraw so the
Cubans went to the Mexicans and the
Mexicans resisted and now they are
putting it into operation so it's not
hopeless but you see how the United
States is going around in these areas of
economics and of trade and of Commerce
and finance to try to make the Cuban
people suffer as much as they can and
this is affecting in a drastic way very
young children and infants and also the
older in other words the most vulnerable
and it is a it is an internal shame on
the United States in my opinion that we
would do such a thing to an entire
country just because we don't like the
system just because they won't come
under our protection basically it's a
kind of a mafia attitude and it has been
that way since Eisenhower well that's
capitalism well it's also the United
States and our tradition of being very
nervous
when we don't control something and when
a country like Cuba slips out from under
our control after we had ruled it
practically as a neo colony or a
protectorate up for 59 years or so then
it makes people nervous because they
know that if the Cubans are successful
in their example of being able to
provide as a poor country the best
medical care in the third world to the
whole population because it's an
inclusion inclusionary system it's not
like we have here where you have this
huge bulk of the population you know
marginalize them but there if everybody
can have adequate medical care if the
schooling is adequate for all and
remember Cuba has more doctors and more
teachers per capita than any country in
the world and they have succeeded in
these areas and it's all state supported
which means people don't have to put
money out for the medical care or for
it's indirectly of course pay the cost
and directly as a whole society but they
don't have to pay the bill at the
hospital and so forth and so that cannot
be allowed to stand it's a very bad
example for the United States and for
all the third-world people the United
States after our we're becoming a third
world country very fast if not already
you not already and so there is a very
large mass of people out there who can
look at Cuba and say well if they can do
it
and on a per capita income of two
thousand two thousand five hundred
dollars a year where ours is twenty two
thousand five hundred dollars a year
what's wrong with what's wrong with our
system I mean maybe we ought to consider
an alternative that's why Nicaragua son
in eastern Nicaragua had to be destroyed
exactly they were a bad example and
that's why Grenada had to be destroyed
because any movement that comes to power
with the idea of providing for all the
people and of escaping the control of
the United States and its economy let's
say the corporations and so forth then
that is bad news here in the United
States and the upper circles of power
and influence and so in Nicaragua
I watched it from the very beginning I
was often there and it was it was a very
sad sight to see the hopes at the
beginning and the the euphoria with the
overthrow of this u.s. installed
dictatorship from the 30s on Somoza and
all the hopes for in spanning education
and the literacy program they adopted
right at the beginning it's similar to
what the Cubans did health health as
well all of those things Cuban doctors
were in there they were setting up
clinics clinics all over the
International Solidarity movement was
was just tremendous for Nicaragua in
those early years and naturally the
United States could not let that stand
and the economic system was working they
had the highest greatest expansion of
their national gross national product of
any country in the Western Hemisphere at
that time that's right that was in the
early years but then you know the CIA
started to reorganize using Argentine
military officers who had worked in this
really it's hard to find words for the
the Argentine's you know in the 70s the
dirty war there but these military
people from Argentina were taken by the
CIA put to work in a Honduras
reorganizing the remnants of the of the
Somoza National Guard and then it became
a huge terrorist operation and as a
matter of fact at the by the end when
when the killing was was stopping in the
late 1980s they had killed something
like 35,000 people and that's 1% of the
population of Nicaragua the comparable
figure for the United States would be
what 2 for 2.5 million people killed
over an eight nine year period I mean
that's more than were killed in all the
wars that the United States ever fought
I checked it out once and it would be a
catastrophe can you imagine if something
happened to this country where 2.5
million people were killed
well it means in Nicaragua there's not a
family that was untouched I mean and and
they have a huge number of amputees now
in
in Nicaragua and a very large program
for getting um
prosthetics for these people because of
the land mines that the Contras put
around and they're still they don't you
know they still haven't gotten them all
out of the ground same thing happened in
Angola exactly Angola's got the very
same problem you know it's well it's
where the CIA goes if you've happens in
one place it's going to happen in
another the CIA's more or less intimated
said well they're out of the covert
action business anymore but I read
recently where they're down in Chiapas
helping the government fight the rebels
there there's not a doubt in my mind
that there in Chiapas they've been there
since day one I'm sure and they Mexico
is just too important to the United
States to leave it to the Mexicans you
know what I mean and I was in Mexico
with the CIA in the 60s and they had a
vast operation going there and
especially in their penetrations and
work with the Mexican security services
and in fact it started with the
president in Mexico our operations a
very close relationship with three
successive presidents Lopez Mateos Diaz
or tossing when it comes to Mexico and
this the southeast of movement what they
have to worry about I think is not just
the armed movement in Chiapas of these
this armed force of the EZLN but as an
inspiration they they triggered the
development of a huge support network
popular movement all over the country
which has come together to support their
demands and the demands are really not
outrageous at all no they're not they're
not outrageous and the sub theses
themselves I could not believe this that
they say we do not want power I mean
that's the first gorilla organization I
think that has ever said that the idea
always was to take power and then impose
or establish or reorganize do whatever
you want to do but they say no we just
want to have democracy in this country
and we want to get the pre out and the
pre is of course is so unpopular now
it's it's it's carrying on through its
it's a patronage job system you know
that's been in
power for a long time so in Mexico I
think they have a much bigger problem
than just the armed movement in Chiapas
but it is spread all over the country
and nobody can tell where this is going
to lead the zapatistas you know had this
industry firend 'im back in august and
september and they had it not only in
Mexico this would referendum on a number
of questions on the direction in which
the people would like to see the country
move and how they would like to see the
Zapatista themselves developed whether
they should convert themselves into a
independent political movement and they
had international people I voted in
thing - because I'm sitting over there
in Germany reading everyday through my
computer the latest happenings in
Chiapas in all over Mexico and so I'm
very interesting I voted on all these
questions there are all series of
questions and people I think they had 80
or 100,000 people outside Mexico who
took part in this referendum and there
were several million in Mexico who what
did you send out questionnaires to
people all around the well in in in my
case all the questions came on through
the computer through the net and I sent
my vote back through the net and in
Mexico they organized tables all over
the country and people went and and
voted on their preferences according to
this list of questions so you can be
very sure that the CIA is in there in a
very big way I imagine they're in there
with Special Forces of the United States
Army right in Chiapas they are doing
communications monitoring I'm sure of
all the transmissions of the Zapatistas
and monitoring the people who come and
go you know the Mexican Army's tried to
make put a ring around the area
controlled by the the EZLN and it's a
it's a very fascinating scene to watch
but when you talk about going back to
your comment about covert action in the
1990s there are some very interesting
things that have come out for example
even though the Cold War is over that
does not mean that the United States is
going to settle for democracy in any
particular country they never have and
the litany is quite long you know
starting from the 50s
of democratic processes what is accepted
here as legitimate electoral process and
pluralistic political parties and so
forth when that goes against US
interests they don't kill they don't
care I mean it's not a matter of
principle for them the principle is
what's good for us
well not fate what's that famous remark
that Kissinger made about the situation
in Chile the other oh we shouldn't stand
by because of the irresponsibility of
the Chilean people and at the same time
then Nixon was telling the CIA to make
the Chilean economy scream but what has
happened now in the 1990s is that in
1990 Bulgaria the Bulgarian Communist
Party the former communists they renamed
themselves as the Bulgarian Socialist
Party and they won the 1990 elections in
the sense that they took 211 of the 400
seats in the parliament do you think
that the United States accepted that all
these international observers were there
from Western Europe and other places and
they all said this was absolute free and
fair there was no fraud at all that we
could detect but the United States
didn't accept that and so nowadays
instead of having just a CIA going
around behind the scenes and trying to
manipulate the process secretly by
inserting money here and instructions
there and so forth they have now a
psychic which is this National Endowment
for democracy anyd and this organization
dates from 1967 a lot of people don't
realize because it was just established
in the I think 83 or so but the idea
emerged from a series of scandalous
revelations in 1967 the worst ones to
that point to hit the CIA and I was in
headquarters at the time that these
scandals broken the gloom there was
something you could you could touch
almost because what happened was the the
long-running CIA's control and
manipulation of the International
program of the National Students
Association in this country which was
the National Organization of University
students came out it was revealed and
that led to revelations of a lot of
other CIA
operations because they were using the
same bogus and real foundations to
channel money into all these different
overseas organizations and I remember
very well the Time magazine at the time
or Newsweek I think it was time they
published a wheel with all these spokes
going out and the CIA was at the center
and then halfway out where all these
these corporate are these foundations
and American organizations and then out
at the end were the foreign groups to
cut the money and the instructions
naturally they will give away money
without being sure that it spent the way
they want to spend and so this was a
catastrophe for the CIA and the next
month of the month after that this would
have started in February in 67 and then
by April I think it was Dante fishell
the congressman from Florida was
proposing the establishment of a an open
system to finance these overseas
organizations and we're talking about
some government organizations abroad
some political parties some media
organizations youth organizations and
student organizations all these kinds of
of so-called pluralist organizations
when in fact they weren't really free
organizations at because to the degree
that they take money and instructions
from the CIA to that degree they're not
free at all right but anyway Michele
came up with this idea but nothing it
didn't go anywhere because the so-called
consensus between the two parties had
broken down over Vietnam and so it
wasn't until the early 80s when Reagan
made his speech in the House of Commons
about the democracy project worldwide
that this began to take on steam again
and finally they decided to copy the
German example each of the major German
political parties has a foundation which
is financed by the German government
before it was West Germany now the whole
country and for example the friedrich
ebert stiff tool is the SPD or the
social democratic party's foundation and
they financed projects all over the
place in four years in the 50s and 60s
and I would guess even into the 70s fact
I know into the 70s even to the early
80s the CIA was channeling money through
these German foundation
I bought for example some money a lot of
money I think it was a million dollars
in war but I'm I'm little hazy on the
amount but anyway it went through the
CIA many who which went through the
Konrad Adenauer stiff though that's the
Christian Democratic Union it went from
there to evil which is a foundation of
the copay the Christian Democrats in
Venezuela and from there it went to the
Christian Democrats in El Salvador to
Duarte for use in the elections I've
forgotten which year maybe 84 something
like that and it was traced some
journalists did this and so that is the
way they would use these German
foundations in the past so now we've got
our own we don't have to use the Germans
unless we really want to anymore because
in 1984 we established this National
Endowment for democracy which is nothing
but a mega conduit and the millions or
the tens of millions that are set aside
for the meddling in the internal affairs
of other countries goes to this conduit
it's like a bank account or something
but they have a board of directors and
they do reports and stuff like that
but then it goes from there to one of
four private foundations one of the
Democratic Party one the Republican
Party or 2/3 the afl-cio and for the US
Chamber of Commerce these groups then
pass it out to recipients in foreign
countries and in the Nicaraguan
elections of 1992 figure was something
like 12.5 million that went from the
National Endowment for democracy through
these conduits to the uno political
movement there it was the party the
coalition you know of uno which is the
most ungodly coalition you can ever
imagine thing from communists all the
way that's right some Oh CSIS that's
right and then they had a trade front
trade union front which also received
money and then they had this Civic
Association Civic Association I think
they call it via silica there that's a
that's an old old technique of the CIA
is to establish a type of civic
organization which will be involved in
monitoring elections and things like
that
and the first one that I know of was
numb fro in the Philippines they
established that when around 1950 51 as
part of the counter insurgency against
the Huck's the the guerrilla movement of
the time because we wanted to have a
vehicle for electing our men president
of the Philippines and we did it through
this organization and fro manfro stands
for National Association for free
elections I think for and free elections
when we were financing and Nam fro was
very successful and our man Ramon
Magsaysay was elected president I think
it was 70 52 53 and unfortunately he was
killed in plane crash 57 and so then we
switched to Marco's and various other
people like that but non Frell never
never faded away and in 1986
remember the elections of 1986 which
Marcos tried to steal
well manfro was alive and well and they
were the ones who denounced the fraud by
Marcos and they then inspired the
movement of people power which forced
him to resign abroad Cory Aquino in his
president so now I was live and well
they tried to copy it in Panama
they sent the president of Chamber of
Commerce in the early 80s 84 they're
more or less in preparation for the 87
elections I think it was they sent him
out to Panama to study the way nefra
worked so he could come back to Panama
and establish another one there and so
he did in Panama it was called Cruces
Ivica or civic crusade and this was what
was used against the Noriega forces in
the streets it became a what they call
Robbie Blanca their you know the the
upper class white people in Panama was
one of those organizations but they did
take to the streets and you can remember
the the pictures on the covers of the
magazines you know when they had the
riots and and Noriega was not overthrown
then but they tried everything in Panama
the CIA was running candidates of its
own all through the 1980s trying to get
Noriega out maybe not all through the
eighties know his utility ended about 86
87 because he was working with the sea
yes it was important for the Contra
operation in in Nicaragua but by 87
everybody knew that the cultures were
not going to do anything they weren't
going anywhere militarily and nor
Diego's importance was in allowing
Panama to be used for training them and
also for resupply but that was over by
87 and that's when the efforts began to
to get him aside leading to the invasion
89 but they were up to here in
Panamanian politics and I'm sure they
are using these different types of
organizations so the covered action
operations go on and as a matter of fact
in not only in Bolivia in Bulgaria did
they overturn this government I didn't
even finish that story but what happened
is all this money from National
Endowment for democracy went in and they
fomented student strikes and
demonstrations trade union strikes
massive street protests and not only was
the money put in by the National
Endowment for democracy but also Paul
way Rick's free Congress foundation all
got involved and this is part of the
Christian Right you know he's the man
who runs all these different
organizations out of the same address in
Washington DC and this free Congress
foundation also got going in there I
guess in coordination with what the CIA
was doing what any D was doing and so
forth and so the elections were in June
the Communist said or the former
communists had won by the end of
November they were out because they made
the country uncover knowable 1991 they
did the same thing Albania they had
elections there free fair no fraud
former communist won the United States
got in there through these different
organizations and the CIA naturally and
they made Albania uncomfortable chilles
same thing same Chile same thing Brazil
in the early sixties same thing we did I
did it we were doing the same thing when
I was in Ecuador in fact we had to coos
to unconstitutional changes of
government when I was there and they
were largely due to what we were doing
and by the time I left after three years
we had what we wanted a four-man
military dictatorship that was carrying
on a very strong repression against the
left
what's the situation in Haiti now that's
a little bit different situation than
say Nicaragua was well Haiti is another
example of 1990s operations our Stede
you know elected with two-thirds of the
vote in 1990 takes office in early 1991
is thrown out in September and there's
strong strong evidence that the CIA was
was pushing this because our state is
not the sort of men they are comfortable
dealing with you know he wants to
elevate the level of the common people
ordinary people just like in Nicaragua
exactly he comes from Liberation
Theology and that's always made the
United States quite nervous yes because
in 1968 at the Medellin Bishops
Conference you know they made this
preffer what they called a preferential
option for the poor and that was a
historical turning point for the
Catholic Church in Latin America I mean
they'd already been doing very good
things certain people you know some of
the Jesuits some of the others and also
doing awful things like in the past
associating themselves with the only car
keys and so forth but 68 and this
decision by the bishops conference was
really a major major event and the
liberation theology moved forward very
fast after that through the Christian
based communities you know that they
established all over Latin America and
these people were dedicated to achieving
social justice one way or another and
honesty comes from that tradition so
anything like that makes people nervous
because it means instability and I
remember so well all those years I was
down there working with the CIA in Latin
America if there's one one thing we
wanted and was our goal was stability
and just as important I guess you could
say the second one is control and that's
not possible when you get a movement
which is clamoring for reform and artist
Reid was trying to help the poor of
Haiti and reorganize the society that
was his program along the lines of
social justice and so forth and so when
that happens it makes the United States
very nervous and they couldn't have it
and so they had to ask they had to ask
the generals to take over and not only
did they ask them to take over but there
there's any number of reports
and I believe in that the CIA was paying
these generals running the military
dictatorship over that three-year period
that killed for 5000 people and I don't
know if you've been following Alan
Aaron's reporting in the nation on Haiti
but he's doing wonderful just wonderful
work he broke the story that in Manuel
Toto constant who had been teaching on
Liberation Theology in the National
Intelligence Service known as sin which
the CIA s which the CIA established in
86 or 87 as a national service to be
used against the narcotics trade coming
through Haiti and the Caribbean on that
area which in fact turned into a
narcotics dealing organization as they
always do or often do but anyway they
set up sin and Toto was teaching on
liberation theology in sin how bad it
was naturally it was sinful and so he
then is asked by the CIA and the DIA who
are working together there that's after
yes that's right after after they have
the coup to form a let's say a militant
action force to balance the forces of
lavell us that's the Irish deed
political movement and so they form the
front for progress of Haiti or something
like that is known as from you know
every bar a PhD from pin dropping in
yeah yeah and so anyway they he
organizes this thing and the CIA pays
him to do it and he's own payroll
they're playing the expenses and
meanwhile these people killing thousands
thousands of Haitians all on our estate
side naturally and it was it was just as
dirty as you can imagine and there we
were behind this and this is covered
action of the 1990s I mean it's not like
like rigging an election or something
it's worse than that in terms of human
cost and all this has come out thanks to
the digging of
Aaron and the publication of his
findings in the Nation magazine so Haiti
is one of those countries which the
United States you know it's like the
rotten apple theory you know Noam
Chomsky talks about this all the time
you know if you get one rotten apple in
the barrel you know it's going to spread
to all the others and so that's why they
can't even allow a Haiti as miserable as
the country is to reorganize for social
justice it's it's just well another
eternal shame on the United States I
guess but now that our estate is back in
they're probably doing everything they
can to to defeat his forces and it's not
working because in the elections that
just were held his his party or his
organization won the Parliament going
away they are in control of Parliament
now and there will be a president
presidential election coming up perhaps
nobody seems to know because there's a
possibility that he might take his extra
three years you know and stay on the
decision hasn't been made yet but I
think the CIA is going to stay in there
in Haiti they're going to stay in Mexico
they're going to do what they always did
communism never really was the problem
you know it was never the problem in
Cuba it did become a problem when the
United States the Eisenhower
administration decided to overthrow the
Revolution and turn the clock back to
the bhakti bautista days it did become a
problem cause then the Soviets got in
there they got a base and they got
troops and Missile Crisis and all that
but that was in reaction it was all in
reaction to the United States aggression
toward Cuba towards Cuba and our
installing missiles all over the world
aimed at the Soviet Union so I think
that in the 1990s and Beyond we are
going to see a lot more of this stuff
that we've known in the past and one of
the main reasons is that the United
States is imposing this so-called
neoliberal economic project and that is
also goes under different names like
free market and so forth but it it
results without fail and it's imposed by
the IMF you know and by the United
States bilaterally and World Bank and
all these organizations WTO
trade organization now and it is imposed
and it means in every single case the
marginalization of a great mass of the
society in a foreign country these are
could be ten twenty forty percent of the
population who are redundant they're not
needed they're superfluous because the
industry that develops and all the
economic development leaves these people
aside just like that is happening now in
the United States and is one of the
reasons why the extreme right movement
in the United States is growing so fast
but that means that there's going to be
resistance and there will be people out
there organizing at the SAP artistas for
example and others in Mexico organizing
to resist and that means that there's a
role for the CIA just like there was
when when guerrillas were operating in
Bolivia or wherever there's a role for
the CIA to collect intelligence on them
to penetrate them divide weaken and
destroy these forces and so we're going
to see this I think just like in the
past the Communist Menace was a bogey
anyway in Latin America and lots of
other places and just look at what this
happened with the communist countries
take China big trading partner partner
now
Vietnam they're getting in there to try
to tap that 78 million person market and
they'll be doing it eventually with Cuba
but Cuba is special they don't want to
lose the idea of control in Cuba and you
have these Cuban exiles here the horrea
muscles of the day who want to go in
there and run the country take the
Burger King and McDonald's franchise and
everywhere they go you just tick off a
list of these countries that have been
subjected to CIA covert actions and you
can just see the the trail of blood and
just horrible things that have happened
to the people in the economy you look at
Nicaragua El Salvador Guatemala Haiti
Vietnam
well Afghanistan Afghanistan Afghanistan
is absolute absolute chaos mess the what
you call in Spanish sequela the
aftermath of of the afghan intervention
is still going on as a you read about in
the paper every single day and the
numbers of people there have been killed
or astronomical the numbers of refugees
is way up there in the millions and all
because of a movement which took control
in the country back in the in the
eighties and which was going to
modernize afghanistan they were going to
change the status of women who until
that time were men's chattels they were
going to educate women to read and write
and afghanistan at that time was a was
living in the past with just a few core
sectors you know which had the education
in the West and so forth and the agency
got in there with the Chinese and the
Pakistanis trying to support the
opposition to this social development
program before the Communists took over
in Afghanistan and before the Soviets
intervened but what is interesting to me
is in the aftermath
how many of these Arab volunteers
Afghanistan is not an Arab country but
they had a lot of volunteers Islamic
fundamentalists from the Arab countries
who went as volunteers to fight in
Afghanistan in Afghanistan they were
they they were volunteers from Algeria
from Morocco from all of North Africa
Egypt to Sudan and other Arab countries
and they went there as volunteers and
they fought first they were trained in
in how to handle the weapons and so
forth by in these camps provided by the
CIA and then they saw action on the
front lines well when it was over these
they're called Afghan ease in their home
countries because they'd gone off to
volunteers even though they're from Arab
countries so these Afghan is our
so-called Afghani went back and then
they started to foment
fundamentalist revolution in their own
country so you see what's happening in
Egypt or in Algeria right now this
Algerian Civil War has taken thirty
thirty-five thousand lives they say but
this is being run and they some of the
main forces there
have served in Afghanistan with the bill
ticket from the CIA and the training and
so forth
same thing in Egypt with the Islamic
group there and of these people who were
tried in New York on the two cases you
know when the World Trade Center bombing
and the other the conspiracy trial for
the tunnels and you know I think half of
those were trained in Afghanistan so you
see it coming home to roost
this is a typical ballerina boooring
effect the other one is from Afghanistan
is the great missile buyback you know
about that one
No well in the early 80s the CIA gave
about 1,000 Stinger missiles to the
Mujahideen those were the anti-communist
forces backed by the United States and
Pakistan and so forth they used about I
think they used about 250 of them so
there were 750 left over and those are
pretty sophisticated well they are
shoulder-fired heat-seeking and they
were the missiles that that turned the
balance against the Soviets it was that
is made the cost so high in terms of
lost helicopters and jets and so forth
that they had second thoughts about
continuing in Afghanistan it was very
effective but they only used about 250
of them I think that's the figure that
sticks in my mind I've got it on on
paper somewhere but that meant there
were 750 left to get back
and naturally agency said we'll take
things back thank you and the
Afghanistan hmm
we're keeping them prevented and so they
disappeared oh and Bush when he was
president I think it was 91 90 91 maybe
both years he had to take tens of
millions of dollars from his special
contingency fund and give it to the CIA
for buying them back in their arse
bazaars all over the place out there
where they were selling them they know
that the Iranians got some and the the
thought of course is the danger and
threat is that they're gonna shoot down
an American airliner or two with these
with these missiles and so then but then
Carter not no court not Carter but
Clinton and getting my presidents mixed
up
Clinton hell they're always things I
miss master Clinton then in the summer
of his first year in office which have
been 93 he also had to put up 40 million
or something like that to give the CIA
especially to buy back these missiles
and it's I haven't read yet how many
they've been able to buy back but
they've got their people running around
from one market to another to another
trying to try to get in as many as
possible and that's the sort of sort of
thing you run into when you get involved
with these kinds of people I don't think
they'll ever probably get them all back
because some are in the hands of the
Iranians met but if they were so naívi
naive as to think they could go to these
Mujahideen in Afghanistan hi fellows Oh
we'll take the missiles back
would you please there's a final
question people say well we need the CIA
other people say we don't need the CIA
some people say well the CIA should be
disbanded because its hands are so
bloody but we do need to replace it with
something else what's your opinion on
the need for an intelligence agency well
first let me say that you know there are
committees on different levels looking
into the current and future role of the
whole United States intelligence
community because there's something like
12 organizations of which the CIA is
only one and they spend twenty eight
billion dollars I think is the accepted
figure for the overall community budget
of which the CIA gets about three
billion and so that's a lot of money
involved and there is a joint White
House Senate committee which les aspin
was heading until he died they are to
report in the coming months I think the
House of Representatives has another
committee going on it groups outside
government like the 20th century fund
are also making their own studies think
tanks in other words and so it's a it's
a period of transition and they are
trying to come up with what the
structure and the missions of the
intelligence organizations should be and
I think it's realistic to to say that
yes we do need an intelligence service
of some sort
there are legitimate targets out there
which have to be have to be taken into
account I'm thinking of international
terrorism I thinking of the
international narcotics trade I'm
thinking of the problem of the
proliferation of nuclear weapons and
chemical and biological weapons of mass
destruction in other words and others so
I think that there is certainly a need
for an intelligent service and
organization no matter what you call it
it doesn't have to be called CIA and the
morning hand plan of dividing the CIA
between the Pentagon and the State
Department that still could could be a
solution but we'll still have to have
some clandestine collection and the
point all these years has been to use
intelligence collection to prevent war
especially by Alki accident or
miscalculation and that was very
important with this Soviet standoff you
know well I think that the most
important things that should be changed
and I don't have any hope right now of
changing these things but the most
egregious activities are the subversion
and overthrow of democratically elected
civilian governments and their
replacement with military dictatorships
of the highly repressive type that
institutionalized torture and disappear
people and so forth
that is one thing that we should really
try to eliminate because it's a disgrace
on the United States
the CIA's support to murderous security
services around the world is another
area that really should be looked into
and these most recent revelations on
Guatemala and the CIA connections with
the murderers of the American Michael
Devine and the husband of Jennifer
Harbury The American Lawyer that is
indication that these types of support
to these security services continuing
and it was happening from the 50s on I
was involved in those are those actives
myself in the 60s those have got to be
stopped and then the I would say the the
third area that really should be looked
into is the general area of covered
intervention in the affairs of other
countries and not just overthrow but to
to try to control and manipulate their
institutions of power whether it be the
press Oh
B of women's organizations or whatever
and so these are my this is my wish list
but I don't have the slightest hope that
it's going to happen because I think
that all these CIA activities are a
product of the domestic system in the
United States and until we change the
domestic system in the United States
reordering the power structure here then
these things are going to go on because
they are needed by a very few in this
country fuel and powerful interests and
they relate very closely to the
operations of multinationals abroad
us-based multinationals abroad but it is
a period of transition right now in the
world at large
it is the largest in the most important
period of transition since the late
1940s into the early 50s it's only a
window of opportunity decisions are
going to be made now about the use of
the intelligence services and a lot of
other international priorities and
domestic priorities in the United States
and I think that everybody who is
concerned should be involved in this but
not alone in concert with others because
an individual as in the trade union
movement you know an individual worker
has no power at all he can be fired and
replaced at will but if you work as a
unite and trade unions with strength
then they have power and the same thing
goes in the political scene or cultural
scene or whatever else other sector you
may speak of and so that is why it's so
important for people to be involved in
groups the group of choice and there are
many activities out there to be engaged
in such as solidarity with Cuba to try
to break down that blockade of 35 years
or with Guatemala so there is something
out there for everyone and we only have
ourselves to blame if we don't take
action now phil was in the CIA for 12
years and then quit after he saw what
the CIA was actually doing all the
terrible things doing in the areas where
he was working particularly in Ecuador
Mexico and ludic why he resigned in 1969
to write his first big book inside the
company or CIA diary since then he's
written five books the last one being on
the run which tells about his experience
after he got out of the CIA when he was
in Europe and trying to write his book
and the CIA was hounding him from
country to country doing everything it
could to keep him from writing this book
would you mind yeah I'm sure you told
this story hundreds thousands of times
before you tell us your famous
typewriter story about sure I'm glad to
I hope we have enough tape for it
because it's a long story but I'll try
to make it short just the bare bones oh
that's okay that's okay we have lobster
oh all right
well what happens is this I just to set
the scene I had left the CIA in at the
end of 1968 and turned against the work
but I hadn't any intention of writing a
book doing anything I wanted to start a
new life and among the things I did was
to reenroll in university I stayed
living in Mexico City where I'd worked
on the Olympics and I went into a
doctoral program in Latin American
Studies at the National Autonomous
University there in Mexico City is a
huge one and as I plowed through these
studies
month after month doing the reading
doing the writing of the papers and so
forth I and I was studying you know the
horrors of the conquest and the genocide
of the colonial period the forced labor
and all of that the the wiping out of
entire culture and then the United
States domination in the post-colonial
period I was thinking thinking and I
came to the conclusion that what I and
my colleagues were doing was nothing
more than a continuation of all this it
started at that time nearly 500 years
earlier and that led me to think that
maybe it wouldn't be a bad idea to
expose what we were doing it had been an
unthinkable idea until then no had ever
done it and I was pledged to secrecy but
I began to think that maybe staying
silent on all this was worse than than
doing it you know in fact I could see
some very positive things in a book and
so I began looking around Mexico City
for resources I needed to reconstruct
events to show our hand at events and I
couldn't find them in Mexico City so I I
had to choose and I chose for the book
came to Europe and spent a year in
France and
I made a mistake early on I wrote a
letter to the leading Latin American or
certainly South American political
Weekly called marcha at that time and
it's publishing amount of the dáil and I
had I had mentioned how we intervene in
elections because they had elections
coming up and I was hoping to to aid the
frente Amplio with this letter which
they did published and I didn't know
they published it so one night in paris
a knock on the door in my hotel and
there is an old friend from the CIA and
we go out and have a few drinks he says
Phil I guess you know that I'm here for
a reason and I said well yeah I think
you are what is it and then he takes out
this thing put some of the papers a
Xerox copy of my article which was
published in this magnet this newspaper
or weekly in Uruguay marcha and he said
mr. Helms wants to know about this
because I mentioned it that I was
writing a book he's the head of the CIA
he was directed in and it sent this
Keith over to see me and anyway I said
don't worry I'm not going to reveal any
secrets I'm going to submit it for
review and all of that I just wanted to
get him off my back well anyway I my
children were visiting it was over
Christmas and New Year's of of that year
seventy one seventy two and so I took
them and in the way I was the morning
went over to the railway station and got
a ticket and we went to Spain got out of
there and then eventually they flew back
to the states to go back to school from
Madrid and I went back to Spain to Paris
but a few months later a young American
befriended me phone whose name was Sal
Ferreira and he was a journalist or he
said he was a journalist an underground
journalist who was representing a couple
of groups in the States and he was over
in Paris to cover the peace talks then
going on between late October Vietnam
and Henry Kissinger we saw each other
from time to time I was living in a very
potent on the west bank just down from
the Sorbonne and
on the corner there was a cafe called
Leung and he came in there and that's
where he met me I'd go down there in the
evenings for a beer or something so I
was desperate for money I was really I
didn't know how I could
you working on my book because I had I
was running out of money I had no money
in fact to speak of just enough for a
little food every day and I was getting
desperate and I had rented a typewriter
from a typewriter shop at Odeon and
eventually I had to turn that typewriter
back in to get the deposit back
in the meantime I had taken a big chance
I had told Sal who I was and what I was
doing hoping he might do an interview he
could sell to playboy for $10,000 and
given me five you know and so he was he
was recording the other stuff on about
the CIA and the book I was working on it
was my only hope to get some money and
he did give me money as a matter of fact
you know a little bit here in a little
bit there just to keep me going and one
time he invited me to dinner the next
week oh by the way when I was with him
I'd noticed surveillance in the street
and I was being followed around from
about February of 1972 on and the first
time that happened that night I went on
a very late at night I checked out of
the hotel and made sure nobody was there
and took a taxi over to the area where a
friend of mine lived a woman whose name
is Katrina in the PUC's section of Paris
and I I asked her if I could say in her
place for a few days it turned out to be
six months or more because I I had to
stay in secret and so I wouldn't tell
anybody where I was living I wouldn't
tell Sal or anybody else
anyway he invites me to dinner we go to
dinner and he says we're walking up the
hill there to to a room of Todd and he
points out this english style pub he
said let's have a beer there afterwards
they've got English beer now I said fine
so we went to dinner came back went into
the pub and there's a bar here and
there's a stool here stool here student
so forth and these are empty and he sits
on the one on the end I sit on the one
next to him we order our beer and in
comes this rather attractive voluptuous
young American woman a woman let's say
carrying a time magazine so he tells you
is America and so she starts to talk to
me and she is a Venezuelan heiress I
mean American but had been raised in
Venezuela and her parents had died and
left her
money and she had just spent the
academic year over in Geneva at the
University of Geneva studying French and
she was going to spend the summer in
Paris so she wanted to know what I was
doing and I said well I'm trying to
write a book and she's old a great
American novel and I said not exactly I
said it's about American foreign policy
in Latin America it's just oh oh isn't
that awful
often I said it's partly about the CIA
Toshio over awful I can't stand those
people that's terrible and so anyway we
talked a little bit and she says well
look call me call me I'll invite you to
dinner
and so she writes out her telephone
number and to gives it to me so I'm
thinking well what is this gonna lead to
and I I didn't call her and I left went
through my routine not to be followed
back to the little room where I was
staying and about a week later I see Sal
and to do some more of this recording
for the interview it was notoriously
slow on that when made which made me
very suspicious and he brings up this
woman he said by the way did Lesley he
she used the name Lesley gun Dunnigan
did Leslie did you call Leslie and did
you talk to her and see her and I said
no no I'm not interested I'm not instead
here you take the telephone number and
you call her he said no no but remember
she's got money
she said she's an arason and maybe you
could talk into us into into supporting
you and financing your book
I said well so maybe maybe maybe I
should talk to her so so what I did was
I called her just oh hello how are you
he has well yeah let's have dinner
come on over and I'll take you to dinner
so she lived down a move-on acid on
repeat talk I went over to her place it
was this big tall modern building it
went up to the studio she had rented and
so we'd say I'm talking have a drink or
something then she takes me out to
dinner
very romantic place with red and white
checkered tablecloths and and and and
candles and everything and have our
steak frequent then we go back to her
place and we're sitting there talking
maybe having another drink a little wine
or something I guess and it was either
that time or the next time that I
decided to tell her who I was and see if
I get some money out of her so I did and
she said oh yes yes I'll do that I'll
help you I'll help you but you know I
can't stand Paris it's too boring I'll
leave you this apartment the studio
apartment for the summer you can have
the key and here's a gun how many
thousands of francs she gave me and I'm
going off to see my boyfriend in
Barcelona and we're going to Majorca for
the summer so I have the apartment I
have the money and all I needed was some
help because I had to get a clean draft
of what I had done so far ready for
Barney Russert of growth press who was
coming through Paris on the way from the
Frankfurt Book Fair back to the States
in October so there's another person who
I'd met in this craft cafe yams a
french-canadian whose name was Torres
and she was doing secretarial work up
she had raised her children in the
United States she had married an
American they were divorced she had a
son and a daughter she used to talk
about all the time and we had a lot of
political conversations she was very
very hip politically so I asked her if
she would Oh as a matter of fact I asked
somebody else first but that's another
story the woman freaked out and and and
had a nervous breakdown when I told who
I wasn't what I was doing I've all
started rolling around in her head no
God had she had to go to the American
Hospital embarrassment then I said well
kay less stress
so I asked her I said sure I'll help you
I'll help you I'll come over there in
the evenings um we'll do it in the
evenings after after I've get off work
because she's working in a law firm over
there that type so I gave her the
address and keys and everything and I
would go over and wait for her and she'd
get there about 7:30 or 8:00 and this
was Leslie Department and you can guess
the under story naturally Leslie was
working with the CIA the whole time and
they were recording everything to resume
were saying in this apartment but anyway
we use the apartment she got the whole
thing done and Leslie then comes back
from Majorca in September and she and
Sal kind of team up together and they're
giving me money still she's giving me
money and then I finish what I'm doing
in Paris
I'm going to go over to London to finish
because the British Museum newspaper
library this fantastic institution has
newspapers from all times in all places
and they had all the local papers from
the places where I'd worked in the CIA
from the times I was working there and
so I could go over there and read all
the newspapers that I was reading you
know when I was there and that's what
made my book by the way because
everything we did of importance came out
in the newspapers save our hand in these
events but that's jumping ahead a little
bit what happens is this
I had this borrowed typewriter from Sal
which I was using and one night lesley
comes in in the rain to a place where
we're going to meet it was a it was a
cafe in the on the West Bank and she
comes in with this typewriter it's a
used typewriter and she said Phil the
guy who owns that typewriter that Sal
gave you his back and he needs it back
immediately but here's one that I bought
for you from a used typewriter store and
so I said Oh fine and I I had to go back
and get that other typewriter from
Katrina's room you know and bring it
back over because the guy had to have so
I I didn't want to carry this one I
didn't need a typewriter I was making
recordings then for for London and these
were operational episodes maybe 40 or 50
secret operations which I was trying to
describe on tape to use over in London
and so I I didn't need the type I put it
into Reza apartment she always left the
door open she wasn't there I just stuck
it in there to have it out of the way
and then I went back to get the other
type ever brought that gave it Leslie
and then a few days later we're at lunch
and Leslie has given me the money that I
need to get over to London and last for
a couple of weeks before they come over
supposedly to help me continue working
on the book and doing the research and
Sal says overlay says by the way Phil
did house the typewriter that Leslie
gave you working and I said well son I
haven't used it yet I didn't need it I'm
doing recordings right now and I left it
in Torres's place well I got the money
but later on I was talking to Sal he
says Phil you know Leslie so upset about
the typewriter she had that terrible
cold and she went out in the rain and
got that typewriter for you and you know
we all know Torrez never locks her
apartment she's already having radio and
other stuff stolen
from there and if the typewriters stolen
less he's going to be so upset and she's
already so hurt
she might not continue for Nancy huh so
I took the typewriter and I took it over
to Katrina's place and it was there for
a few days before I was ready to go to
London and on a Saturday afternoon I'd
finished the tapes went out to get a
beer came back up the steps and this was
a this building was where the servants
lived to a very elegant building in the
16th or ones' bond which is they said
richest area of Paris and so as a small
maid's room where Katrina and I where I
was staying with her and so I came up
the steps went down this dark dark
hallway and there in front of her door I
saw these two people a man and woman
standing at the door as if they just
knocked but as I approached down this
dark hallway they backed off from the
door of the other side of hall and began
to embrace and to kiss it see it looked
like and they had coats on it was
already I think the end of October early
November and so I stopped at her door
and knocked and she opened the door and
and she started to laugh at the people
oh that's a Weidman wait a minute I
think I think they're monitors or
something I think the CIA has caught me
I think they've caught me I went in
closed the door and the reason I thought
that was that Katrina used to like to
listen to the radio it was the Phillips
table model recorder thing with radio
and FM and all that and for the last
days when she was listening to it there
was this beeping sound on the radio and
I thought it was a propagation from ort
F which is the radio television Center
in Paris and we're so close there but it
was a kind of an irritating he was like
B P P P P P like that and as I was
standing there and these people were
embracing and I was waiting for it open
the door I was hearing the beeping son I
thought my god that sound we hadn't even
spoken about it but I was thinking it so
loud now it's coming all the way out in
the hallway when she opened the door I
notice the radio was off Oh
and so I said listen I was hearing a
beeping sound from that I was hearing on
the radio but I was hearing it out in
the hallway the radio was off she said
yeah the guy's got a hearing aid in his
ear and they've got those bulky things
under their coats and so so I went in
there and I said I'm going to try to
find out what's in there because they
found me now and she said well I'll
follow them and so they went down the
steps
and she was after them but they forgot
that it's on the middle level like on
the third floor level or so because this
building is built on the bank going down
to the Seine and it doesn't have a
street in front of it it has this
passage it's a walkway that goes down
and so they went on with all the way to
the bottom where the garbage cans are
kept for everybody in the building and
there's a door there but you have to
have a key to get in or out of that door
and they were trying the door and trying
they couldn't she told me that when she
came back up she went over and fiddled
around with some garbage cans and just
watched them and they whispered some
things and they went back up and how it
disappeared she came back to him his
story and then I started fooling around
with this typewriter and I I thought
damn I fell for it and I turned on the
radio and you could get this signal at
several frequencies but there was one
that was really loud or strong and so I
began to turn the I thought that they
had DFT's some kind of transmitter you
know that's how they actually find
that's right and that's how they could
find the box which is where they found
me and so I began to turn the typewriter
round slowly like this and depending
upon the axis of the of the box that
held the typewriter the signal was
louder or softer so I knew there was a
directional transmitter in there and I
had to find it I thought first it might
be in the roller or wherever but then I
started checking the inside of the roof
of the box and I pulled off the the
upholstery and there before my eyes was
this most amazing thing it was a
transmitter homemade transmitter all
these transistors and batteries and
antennas and things all in notches
carved out of a very thin piece of
plywood there wasn't even a half maybe
quarter inch plywood or something and it
was an amazing sight to see and I
of course realized and then I had to get
rid of a lot of papers the next day and
I I went out on the Seine and there was
a little beach there where I took a
whole suitcase full of papers to make a
bonfire because it was too much to tear
up and and all that so I made this
bonfire out there and I'm blazing and
everything and and it was just down the
river from the Eiffel Tower and you
could see it right over there and I one
time I looked up and there was this guy
with a camera with a handheld camera a
motion fishing camera and he was
supposedly filming the Eiffel Tower but
I think he was filming me doing this
bonfire these papers and so I kind of
freaked at that but anyway that the the
result was that I left her place and I
went over to Mont on the other side of
Paris and I change hotels for the rest
of the days I was there maybe three four
days because it takes one day for the
slips to catch up with the police the
registry register slips that you have to
fill out in the hotels in Paris and so I
was changing hotels staying one day
ahead of the CIA and the French police
and then I took the boat over to took
the train up to Calais and across to to
Folkestone and on the boat they were
waiting for me the British immigration
and when I got up there they said oh yes
take a seat over there mr. ajm and we'll
call you and so time went by and I had
all these tapes and I had all the work
that I'd done in person a year and
before that Mexico and I I thought what
is going to happen and I that takes a
very incriminating and I thought they
might just take him away from me
and so it was raining like hell on the
crossing it was quite rough and
everything but I went up in that rain on
the top deck I threw the tapes all my
tapes over because I didn't want them
caught or anybody to see them so that
was gone and then they called me back to
the desk and said where he's staying
well I had this old copy of Europe on $5
a day that everybody
at that time not European $100 a day I
suppose but it was right it was the
cheapest places to live and so I had
chosen some better breakfast by our guys
Square and near near the stations st.
Pancras and Kings Cross and I gave him a
wrong address also taken but it was a
little bit more expensive than this
cheapest place so I lied to them and
went on from the train to this place ins
checked in this bed and breakfast and
this was the most depressing area oh god
it was awful
over Christmas of 1972 because it was
foggy and cold and rainy and they had
these yellow street lights in London in
the section of old red brick buildings
and ugly and it was a far cry from cafe
au lait and croissants in Paris every
morning but anyway I continued on the
book I got the money from Penguin Books
and that solved the problem then I just
went on and did the book and in the
meantime the day I left Paris to come to
London Torres was arrested and I learned
this on the telephone because I'd made
telephone arrangements to speak with
salan and Leslie after I got to London
because they were coming over I talked
to Sal and he says Oh everything
terrible has happened
you can't imagine they picked up the res
and they took her into the prefecture
and they talked to her all day about you
interrogating her wanting to know this
want to know that and Leslie got so
scared with this that she went down to
Madrid I said white to Madrid she's got
to come over here she got the money he
said well I'm going down there to you're
too hot right now we've got to we got to
all go down to Spain and so then they he
goes down to join her then we're on the
phone all the time they are calling me
now because the British pay telephones
could be called from outside you know
they would ring it so we make plan and I
go there and stand by the phone until it
rang in and so they went down to Malaga
and they did everything they could do to
get me to go to to Spain and I of course
was on to I mean I knew even though it
had doubts before now I had proof and so
I wouldn't go but I said send me the
money and I'll go in an indirect way so
I don't have to go through airport
passport controls and things like that
I'll take train I'll take buses things
like that and they wouldn't do it I said
no I'll come I'll come
I'm naturally going to just keep the
money what I'm going to go by any means
to Spain
that time it was Franco fascism I knew
the CIA was thick as thieves with the
fascist security services I knew that
from my own experience and so I wasn't
gonna go but in the meantime I got
relief from penguin books and that
changed my whole life I was able to go
onto the book
Leslie disappeared and so went back to
Paris and they didn't come over and then
I wrote the book it came out and after
the book had come out maybe a year or so
afterwards I was in Geneva and I
happened to meet someone who said Oh
mister i'm ecuadorian you know and i've
read your book and it is fabulous
everybody in ecuador is up in arms about
it and we know all the names that were
in there and by the way I think I know
that Leslie Dunnigan that was working
against you in Paris this is years
afterwards you know is like from 72 to
76 or 77 776 prom and I said what do you
mean he says well I think she's working
at the United Nations right now but she
uses a different name here she calls
herself Janet Strickland I said well how
do you know she's the same person well
my best friend is the Spanish guy who
worked for the UN here too and his best
friend is a Spanish guy and she told her
boyfriend who's a Spanish guy that she
was working to the CIA against you and
he told my friend and my friend told me
and I said well I wonder if we can see
her he said oh yeah I know her offices
he was working for one UN agency she was
working for the ILO the International
Labor Organization and so we drove over
to the ILO building parked in the
basement I sat in the cafe while he went
up to see if she was in her office and
she was in the office he came back down
so I went up the elevator 9th floor so
walk down the hallway around the corner
and I look different then because when I
was in Paris and she was working on this
thing I had very long hair I had a huge
hot - style mustache and you know I was
pretty creepy looking but by this time I
cut my hair and I was normal and so I
just walked down that hallway looked in
very carefully and walked on and it was
it was she and so I went on back down
got with him and then I was back in
Paris and I wrote up the story and I
took it to Renee Buckman an editor at
noodle observe
which is the sort of Time Newsweek of
France guy I knew and he said he loved
the story and they wanted to publish it
and here the CIA person was now working
on another name in the UN no less so he
said what about photographs I said me
photographs I don't have any photographs
ever you can get the photographs over
maybe no no you wouldn't hurt to get you
and she together I said you mean a
confrontation
I said yeah I've got two photographers
over there who are great people they
could do something marvelous we have
really good photograph
I said Renee if you'll pay my way over
there and pay the hotel I'll do it I'll
try to do so back to Geneva I go to see
Danny
Janu who's the stock for a woman and her
friend Hans also photographer they're
working together and so we make our plan
and the plan included going down after
after this thing in her office if we
could do it then we would not go to the
elevator but we thought there'd be a
fuss so we would go down we would find
the stairway and we knew where it was
and we would go down four or five
flights real fast and then go over to
the elevator and out and out and you
know we had the card so we got it
already and the night before in the
hotel I practiced in my bathroom mirror
the most ferocious looks like it put on
my face
because I wanted to scare a really
skills and you know what out of her and
so the next morning we got in the car
they had all their equipment over to the
ILO barn basement up the elevator to her
floor down the hallway and around the
corner and the door is closed where it
had been open for I said oh my god she's
not working today I knocked on the door
come in and so I open the door and walk
in and start walking over to her desk
which was on the other side by the
windows Donny goes over here to this
corner
Hun's closes the door behind him and
stands in front of the door and I walk
over to and I'm leaning over
or dead that's like this and I'm saying
hello Leslie using the old name you
thought I'd never find you I said well I
found you and now I'm gonna get you you
could have gotten me killed back then
and now I'm gonna get you and and she
let out this primal scream you can
imagine she got up she went over to the
door and we had this fabulous photo
taken by Danny where she's she's really
big she was tall tall maybe in those
heels she was over six feet and so she's
grabbing him by the arm to pull him away
from the door and she's screaming all
the time she opens the door and goes
running down the hallway screaming at
the top of her voice we hustle out to
the stairwell down down to the car and
out back to the studio got the
photograph they came out perfect oh
great and so back on the flight plane to
Paris give it all to Renee and coming
out on Thursday about four days later
Thursday I go to the newsstand buy the
magazine where's the story it's not in
there and I call ready I said Renee what
the hell is this and he said Oh Phil I'm
so sorry I'm so sorry
john danielle has killed the story and
Jean Danielle was the chief editor he
happened to be the man that Kennedy had
sent to see Fidel in November of 63 and
he was about improving relations and he
was sitting in Fidel's office when Fidel
got the first word of Kennedy's
assassination and John and John donielle
had told Renee well we're not in the
business of exposing CIA operations and
so it was dead and I didn't do anything
until more on the story until November
when my deportation crisis started in
Britain and this was brought on by Henry
Kissinger who second Secretary of State
then made this long trip over there I
mean this secret trip over there and
forced the British to take action
against me and started a whole series of
deportations but the Sun newspaper in
London I mean all the media descended on
me in Cambridge and the Sun wanted their
special angle you know they're the third
page nude at noon every day of the
tabloid newspaper of South for million
five million copies a day and so they
wanted some kind of sex angle and I
thought well I'll give you a story and
so I gave him the Leslie
Janet story and don't if they didn't
find Leslie Dunnigan they got their New
York bureau on to it and they found
Leslie Dunnigan a motel clerk in Georgia
and she swore that she'd never works the
CIA never worked against me had never
even been to Europe and so it was
obviously a false lead the last question
was have you ever heard of a Janet
Strickland oh sure she was my best
friend we grew up in Caracas together oh
so she switched me Janice Strickland
apparently was a real name and she took
her friends died entity and so then they
found the family they were in a enormous
villa in Palm Beach and Leslie Janet was
there it was her parents place and her
father turns out to be the head of all
the Exxon operations in Latin America
and the photographer and the journalist
go down there and the father comes down
and threatens to punch the you know the
photographer and the guy he got a
picture and so the son then ran a
three-part series on this the spy who I
forgot know what that headline was but
it was front-page stuff you know and
that's the story and I don't know where
she is now
salad disappeared gosh and the circle
was I told you it was a long story the
circle is complete the oil man's
daughter was working for the CIA
incredible in Co but in any case I have
right now a a lawsuit going in the
federal district court in Washington
under the Federal Tort Claims Act for
six million dollars because we found in
documentation that I received under the
foi a in a long-running lawsuit from
late 70s to early 80s that the CIA had
committed criminal actions against me
during that period in which I was in
contact with Sal and Leslie early 70s
and the documents are highly censored so
we didn't get the exact nature of this
but it happened that the CIA tried to
get a criminal indictment against me
when my first book first came out this
is early 75 and
he was the director and they had to back
down because the Justice Department who
which was getting the facts to take to
the grand jury told found discovered all
this illegal activity in the files they
told the CIA if we indict and prosecute
then AG is going to have access to all
this through criminal discovery
procedure they said no no I can never
see the light of day and five times in
the 70s starting in 75 including when
George Bush was director they tried to
get an indictment against me and five
times they back down because this was so
sensitive and I think it's going to come
out now in my torts Claims Act torts
claim lawsuit that this was a murder
plot it was a plot to make me disappear
and that the fridge the Spanish services
were going to do the job if they could
get me to go to Spain that is sahlan
Lesley not that they knew what was
really going to happen their job was to
get me in Spain and then the Spanish
would take over and there was nothing to
them to you know disappear somebody yeah
goes period so I'm hoping I'm hoping
that we will get the real all the facts
out and and find out what they're really
we're planning that's how ironic you're
doing some work now studying the for
your new book I think studying the
development and the history of the CIA
OSS Nazis and neo-nazis is that correct
yes in a way
what I'm doing is two things I am
teaching a course at the University of
Hamburg entitled the CIA the Cold War
and right-wing extremism and the content
of those lectures in that course and
sources and so forth they are going to
be a book so that the lectures will be
chapters of a book and I'm I don't know
when I had that's finished I hope it's
uh I haven't finished next year but I'm
teaching the course in any case as I go
along because it's in development and
what I'm trying to do is write a
selected history of the Cold War in and
show how there is a continuity between
the fascist and Nazi movement of the 20s
and 30s and 40s the Mussolini Hitler in
various other countries with what's
happening in Western Europe
and the United States today because one
of the most phenomenal things that has
occurred and hasn't gotten all that much
publicity except with Oklahoma City it
is beginning to is the growth of the
extreme right in Europe and in the
United States that is Western Europe and
the United States and Canada over the
last 10 or 15 years it's to me it's
really alarming and it's due in part to
the fact that United States policy after
the war in Western Europe kept these
movements alive and they used the Nazis
and the SS and the war criminals to
continue the war against the Soviet
Union that is the United States she took
over the German war against the Soviet
Union and use these people to continue
it but not as open warfare with troops
and so forth it was an underground
warfare it was the Cold War and the CIA
was one of the most important if not the
most important instruments in the Cold
War in carrying on this struggle against
the Soviet Union and all of Eastern
Europe its allies and they were carrying
on an undeclared war for 10 years
through paramilitary operations and what
happened was as the Red Army was
advancing to the west the people who had
collaborated with the Nazis during the
occupation of the Baltic areas of
Eastern Europe of Belarus of Ukraine and
parts of Russia where they found
fascists everywhere and they formed SS
battalions and it was really these local
people in the Baltics it wasn't the Nazi
SS or roughen SS so much who massacred
more than a million Jews but it was the
local people who formed because there
were 500,000 non-germans organized into
roughen SS units and these were the ones
that hunted down all the comments they
can find all the social stake and find
all the trade units they can find and
especially all the Jews that they could
find and those huge massacres like Bobby
are those were carried out largely by
the local people who
were fascists before Germany ever
invaded matter of fact the Ukrainians
after the the Bolshevik Revolution they
formed an organization of exiles in
Paris
so did Russians this is the 20s and
these people are cultivated by the Nazis
and trained and there's a there was a
Ukrainian army on the front lines with
the German troops as from the oun as
they marched in in 1939 or 41 actually
when they they cross the border but
these people retreated back with the
retreating Nazi troops and by war's end
you had something like seven million
displaced persons or refugees in these
camps all over mostly in West Germany
and the United States then began to
recruit and to organize from these camps
and the key figure there was Hitler's
chief of intelligence for the Eastern
Front Reinhard Galen and Galen came from
a Prussian family Russian military
tradition and he had made his life's
work of studying the Soviet Union and in
his organization which had the German
initials fh o that means foreign armies
east in german he had accumulated the
most marvelous records of any country in
the world i mean by far away on the
soviet union and he had been doing this
since the 1920s and he had risen very
fast he's only 43 years old when the war
ended he had a lifetime ahead of it and
so what does he do the last days of the
war he micro films all the files he puts
a microfilm in steel drums and they load
them all on trucks and with his top
people they drive from their office
there their headquarters near Berlin all
the way down to the Alps in Bavaria and
they start trudging up or getting the
trucks up there and then carrying these
drums up into a meadow where they buried
them and they walk back back down the
mountains and they waited for the Clarks
army to come through I think it was
Clark and once they were in occupied
territory of the Americans they left
their hotel
wherever they were staying I think
they're in a hotel and turned themselves
in and Galen he was a general he
presented himself as a general
surrendering to the American and he said
I have some interesting things to tell
you and he had his principal aides of
course with him and everything and and
his main chiefs of sections and all that
they had our plan
they laid low after the war ended before
ghen eyes later and so they took Galen
to Camp King which had laid the German
name was do log left and this is where
the Germans brought all the downed
pilots and crews for interrogation it
was just north of Frankfort a big
military compound base well we took over
that the United States Army took over
this base and renamed at Camp King and
there they they debriefed
Galen on what he'd been doing what he
had and he made a proposition said I
want to continue my war against the
Soviets well the Soviets were after him
because he was a war criminal he was
responsible for interrogating or for the
interrogations of the millions of Soviet
prisoners of war in the different camps
in Germany and they died by the millions
but he was in charge of getting the
information out of them that they were
capable of giving and torture and you
know all that was going on and so the
Soviets were looking for him to try him
as a war criminal they asked the
Americans have you arrested Galen do you
know anything about him you can guess
the answer no we don't know if they
don't know I think so in order to
protect him they flew him to Washington
he turned himself in and early May of
1945 and by June or July he was in in
Washington at one of the military
installations in Washington stayed there
a year and the counterintelligence core
that this was before the CIA was
established set him up in business back
in Germany and it became known as the
org the Galen operation or beening
organization the Galen organization and
then he started recruiting all these
people including SS including war
criminals and so forth and they took
over an SS compound in
pulak a little town just south of munich
and that's where they started up and
then they also opened offices in
different places under commercial cover
and so forth and CIA took the whole
thing over in 47
but the Galen was very he was the key
figure in recruiting these people from
Eastern Europe to go to the training
camps to be trained in military skills
as saboteurs and so forth and then they
were sent back into their home countries
to foment rebellion to to [ __ ]
economic development or recovery after
the war you know so there could be this
big contrast between eastern and western
Europe these things went on for ten
years and Galen was one of the principal
figures they of course we're never able
to to really take control of any of
these countries but the outbreak of
violence in Berlin in the early years of
early 50s of Poznan in Poland 53 I think
56 in Hungary did a lot of damage in the
East East Germany for example they were
often caught though and it happened that
one of the big operations in the late
40s and early 50s was to overthrow the
government of Albania and restore King
Zog as in power he was sitting in Egypt
waiting to go back to Tirana and this
operation was a strange failure because
they had all these teams organized and
they brought them in in maritime
operations on the sea they brought them
overland from Greece they dropped them
in from black overflights what were
known as black overflights in them and
one after another after another got
rolled up
sometimes they forces were there waiting
for it and they would they would double
the WT operators WT the wireless the
radio operator and they would then give
them disinformation to send back and of
course they were they were sending under
duress and and there were suspicions and
so forth until finally when Philby
defected that kim Philby the Soviet
penetration of the British intelligence
service they knew what had gone wrong
because Philby was the British officer
on the British side for this Albanian
operation and so he was telling the
Soviets everything in advance and they
telling Albanians and and so
there are several different examples if
there's one in Poland also known as wind
wi n which were the polish initial for
the organization and this was supposedly
the remnants of the Home Army the
so-called Home Army that had been under
control of the London poles during the
war which the British and the Americans
wanted put in power there and the
Soviets refused and that was one of the
major factors that opened up the Cold
War but for years they were dropping in
gold bars gold coins weapons of all
sorts and ammunition stuff and till
finally one day on polish national radio
they came on the air and exposed the
whole thing and the way it all started
was that they had sent this general to
London to say what his forces were back
in Poland and they bought and then they
organized all this stuff through this
general who was really working for the
poles and start so there are lots of
these cases and these paramilitary
operations were finally ended they were
responsible for the for fomenting the
uprisings in East Germany in the early
1950s in the Poznan uprising in Poland
and then the Hungarian Uprising in 1956
but they the the radio broadcast to
these people have been ambiguous by that
time you know nineteen fifty on they had
one radio operation going to all the
different languages of the Soviet Union
and they had that was radio first radio
liberation but then they changed it
because they weren't going to liberate
anybody so they changed it to Radio
Liberty and then there was Radio Free
Europe which broadcast in the languages
of the other Eastern European countries
both were based in Munich and both were
hot houses for war criminals from those
countries because not only did these
these Nazi collaborators from the
various countries of Eastern Europe come
back and then let themselves be formed
into paramilitary gangs to go back but
also they flocked to these radio
stations because they had the languages
and they had the political background
and so forth so you had all these
fascist war criminals in the CIA funded
radio stations they were not known as
CIA funded at the time supposedly they
were private donations from the United
States and so forth but
anyway those paramilitary operations
ended after the Hungarian revolt of 1956
there was a special investigation
Eisenhower any they call him off
but the propaganda and the political
operations continued so in this book I'm
writing and in the course I'm teaching
I'm trying to show how these efforts to
to continue the war against the Soviet
Union
using the Nazis and fascists and so
forth and war criminals how these
provided a continuity for the survival
of these movements which is today so
manifest in Eastern Europe and Western
Europe and in the United States although
it's a different situation over here
because it's very large religious
content to the extreme right movement
here and in between to show how fascist
or fascist style governments were
installed in so many places around the
third world and of course it starts in
the Philippines and goes to Vietnam
continues through the whole American war
in Vietnam and all over Latin America
and even in Africa in Korea for example
with the partition of Korea in 1945 I'm
trying to show how there was no real
democratic principle behind this policy
it was pragmatic and without principle
really it was simply to make sure that
these governments were on our side
against the Soviets and that they
allowed our companies come in and
operate and and so forth and so on but
there are so many fascinating areas of
Greece for example is one of the more
fascinating places because there was a
very big resistance in Greece to the
Nazi occupation from about 1941 on and
the main resistance forces were there
was a coalition and the principle or the
strongest in the coalition were the
Communists in Greece and the Nazis
formed what they called security
battalions made of Greeks and these were
military units and they were their job
was to eliminate the resistance and so
it was Greek on Greek fighting all
through those years and then at the end
of the war the British invaded Greece
because the liberation forces the Greek
Resistance forces they took over the
whole country they set up an entire
administration model of Greece and the
British invaded to put them down just
like the French invaded in Vietnam to
put down the the liberation forces there
and then they set up a provisional
government that brought the King back
and so forth and then the Greek Civil
War started because of all the
repression against the the liberation
forces this this civil war goes on from
47 to 49 and after it's over the CIA
establishes a national Greek
intelligence service known by the
initials k YP that's the Greek letters
for CIA they give the same name and this
was formed with the officers from the
old security battalions the fascists
hunters of the liberation forces and
these are the same men who in 1967
overthrew the democratic government and
established a seven year reign of
military dictatorship with the
institutionalization of torture forced
exile of thousands of Greeks and so
forth Italy another very interesting
interesting case where even as the
United States and Britain were the
occupying powers in Italy after the war
they allowed the Mussolini fascists to
establish a new fascist party which and
it was fascism was illegal it was
outlawed after the war but still Giorgio
Alma Dante for example who had been
Mussolini's last minister of propaganda
in the so called sallow Republic which
is a puppet public puppet puppet
government run by the germans in north
of italy in the last months of the war
he established the italian social
movement or msi in 1946 right under the
noses and with the approval or
acceptance by the united states and
britain they could have stopped it but
that party
survived through the years and grew and
grew and grew until it came into
government last year and this is a party
which states from the mussolini party i
mean it's a direct descendant and it's
run now by fini John Franco fini and
they are a neo fascist party
they in coalition with the Berlusconi
force Italia and the Northern League the
three parties came to power last March
and a day or two or two after the
elections fini the leader of the
neo-fascists now in power says Mussolini
was the most outstanding statesman of
the century so you see that there is a
continuity there and it's thanks in
large part to US policies because we
were the dominant factor even though the
British were involved as junior partners
the French as junior partners and so
forth and it's it's just fascinating to
see how these movements developed and
the the the inspiration for the neo-nazi
movement in Germany in the 1990s are
these old Nazi war criminals like
Autorama and Kristofferson and there are
a lot of names of former SS people war
criminals who either were never punished
or were punished with a slap on the
wrist and who never changed their views
they are unrepentant old Nazis who are
the inspiration to the younger
generation today and these are the
people who in conjunction with the
skinheads are firebombing the homes of
Turks of their cultural clubs and and
killing killing dozens of people so it's
a it's a really kind of complex but
quite fascinating scene and that's why
I'm so interested in doing a book on it
in fact it's well along but your book
going to include the bringing over into
the United States a lot of these fascist
Nazi emigres is attended and setting up
organizations in conjunction with the
Republican Party oh yes in fact I didn't
mention but the the overthrow of the
elected Bulgarian government in 1990 was
carried out on behalf of the way work
organization I mentioned the free
Congress foundation that was carried out
were led by laszlo Pastore and Laszlo
pastor is a Hungarian who was a youth
leader in the most fanatical of the
Hungarian Nazi organizations it was
called the Arrow Cross and he was a
convicted war criminal he had to he was
I think sentenced to two years after the
war it was it was a hardly a sense
because he was responsible for rounding
up he was involved in the rounding up of
tens of thousands of Jews to send to the
extermination camps this is during the
40s before the end of the war while
while Hungary still had this Nazi regime
under Admiral horthy but now the [ __ ]
the regime has been rehabilitated in
Hungary but pasture is the man who was
one of the major leaders of the
Republican ethnic electoral
organizations and they went into the
communities where there were people from
Eastern Europe and their clubs and so
forth you know in the middle western
here and there and this this ethnic
nationalities organization the
Republican Party was was chock-a-block
with fascists and Nazis from that period
in Eastern Europe they brought them over
here but they brought them over here for
different reasons the Apollo moon
landing was engineered and organized and
made possible through Nazi war criminals
like Verner von Braun these people who
came over and ran the Apollo program in
fact ran the whole United States rocket
program from 45 on had run the the
underground factory for the v2 rockets
and there was a it was in an old salt
mine which had been dug out much larger
and there they created this underground
factory that was invulnerable to bombing
and along sided they established a work
camp called Dora it was a concentration
camp and over a period of about two
years I think the figure is around 35 or
40 thousand people who died as slave
laborers to make the factory and then to
be the workers in the factory and these
men were responsible for that and they
were bought by the United States over to
this to this country and put in the same
work here and Otto Rudolf for example
was one of the principals along with fun
Brown and they eventually deported him
back to
Germany and he he had they'd all become
US citizens several died von Braun died
but Rudolf lived on slightly long enough
to be to be deported and here ounces
your citizenship in the US Consulate
General in Hamburg where I live so you
had them coming back you had Project
Paperclip for example there was a mad
rush for the German technology because
it was so for so much further advanced
in the United States or Britain
paperclip was the code name for breed
code name was for yes they had these
teams of army people who knew just where
they were going to go and they know who
to look for and they've made this study
all through the war and so they had
targets here there and everywhere and
they were rushing to get these people
before the Soviets got them and so as a
bad scene at the end of the war in the
months afterwards because they were
grabbing these people and bringing them
back as fast as they can could and they
didn't care whether they were war
criminals or whatever they did they gave
them new names in certain cases were the
worst cases and they protected them they
they violated violated US law right and
left bringing these people back but that
was that was the day I mean that was the
scene then and you know it it's no
different from today who follows the law
today in these things up yeah
and so that's why it's so important for
people to be involved in groups the
group of choice and their many
activities out there to be engaged in
such as solidarity with Cuba to try to
break down that blockade of 35 years or
with Guatemala so there are something
out there for everyone and we only have
ourselves to blame if we don't take
action now because with the huge growth
of the extreme right in the United
States now with the militia movement and
the Christian patriot movement the hope
of paramilitary culture these are the
potential Brownshirts
of the future in my opinion and the same
exists in Europe where the electoral
parties are doing very well in France
and in Austria and Italy and in Belgium
and in Norway but here in the United
States there these extremist parties are
not but the Christian Right which is
extremist in my opinion and they want to
impose their own concept of morality on
all the rest of us or civil law and so
forth you know you know that they have
taken over the control of the state
Republican Party apparatus in between 20
and 30 states and they are determined
they've they said it just straight up
front
we are going to take control of the
Republican Party by the year 2000 this
is Pat Robertson's group but there are
many others who are even worse than that
the country is peppered with these
extremely extremist organizations and
all they're lacking really is a
charismatic leader and there's one out
there I'm sure so we'll only have
ourselves to blame if one day there's
knock on the door and they're coming for
us because we didn't take the
opportunity when it was there to make
sure they never could do that